la vessie alors gérard et artus on a
plein d'anecdotes sur vous il ya disait
des anecdotes qui vont s'afficher dans
l'écran vous allez devoir deviner à qui
elle correspond de regarder j'ai déjà
parlé un qqc qui certes us ou cgra
annoncé gérard à bon vous présenter deux
mois de thérapie
merci bien moooh exactement un rap etc
ou pas ça très technique c'était là tu
as aussi rapide oui je parlais à
quelqu'un c'est le genre c'est
l'expression par exactement regardez
la thérapie en général de nous trouver
en disant qu aux âmes en cuma tu étais
malade
[Musique]
pour bien réussir votre cas est le
raisin le de préférence et il vaut mieux
avoir un faitout en cuivre ah oui ça
soulage et
une caille bien fraîche ça fait du bien
200 g de beurre aux miracles bien frais
aussi comme la caille le beurre
ça ne nuit pas complètement
je ne sais pas si on pourrait refaire
des émissions comme ça parce qu'ils
allaient ils allés très loin si vous
aviez parlé très loin des
caleçons
j'ai déjà failli vomir j'ai des livres
j'ai déjà fait faire vomir un animateur
télé
cyril lignac away sera pas nous pas non
regarde
faire masser avec une couche tout
simplement vous prenez la couche comme
ça ça vous l'accroché la
banqueroute le bord
voilà donc
je vous embrasse une couche
[Rires]
c'est reparti
tiago évidemment pour pas que c'est de
la merde
c'est important de le dire non bien sûr
ne faites pas ça chez j'ai déjà été la
doublure du james bond
ça marche pour les
mâles vous gérez oui je crois que j'ai
fait un film bras courts métrages et
courts métrages produits fumés rigueur
pour venir je jouais le rôle de jambon
ouais
qu'avec 14 ans tu veux quand tu veux
qu'on le revoit
tubes au palais comme tu meurs il avait
14 ans en rien au spa une bonne fée où
s'est perdue
[Musique]
plus envoyez pas que tu avais la moule
fermé parce que
c'est un pull que magna
ya de l'idée à la série réalisée en
[ __ ]
mais c'est son premier court métrage à 2
millions de budget
n'a pas fait beaucoup d'entrées mais
même sans cela c'est maman qui me
l'avait tricoter aimé chauveron un tel
mode des déchets niang est en fait la
honte
g j'ai déjà arrêté j'ai déjà été arrêté
dès qu'une fausse paire de testicules
par la douane
s'est regardés
de bruxelles j'ai fait de la postsynchro
est mon ami qui fait des effets cinéma
m'a donné ce papier
j'arrive à la gare évidemment les
policiers me voyais ce pas qui me
demandent de l'ouvrir avec leur plaisir
monsieur l'agent cautionna dedans les
copains il ya les effets spéciaux j'ai
fait faire pour la pièce de théâtre
et donc voilà donc pour continuer mon
chemin j'ai été obligé de montrer
maternelle
[Applaudissements]
je suis descendu du train et je rêvais
de me faire contrôler et en plus j'ai tu
vois j'avais casquette noire paulo
machin sans aucune valise sans rien
juste ce petit paquet sous le bras mais
il pensait que c'est les fausses plaques
d'immatriculation et modifier des
plaques et tout financer des couilles
je vous promets c'est des couilles si on
va être obligé de voir je fais avec
plaisir j'en rêvais et je leur ai sorti
est-ce que je peux préciser que le film
conte à quoi est fait
non coté de
mêlée d'où les deux vont voir avec la
cohabitation va pas se mentir vous avez
déjà fait disparaître après j'aurai
juste qu'on voit ça pour marc surprise
surprise
c'est un décès un des plaignants c'est
un des plus gros piège c'est je peux le
voir deux fois tu l'avais sarthe us ou
pas évidemment délicat avec l'ordinateur
regardez
bien oui mais ça me fait peur [ __ ] de
triomphe le jour et tendre même des
pailletes un
plus au total entre pour le qatar vie
pour la vache mais un couple recueille
pas les coups sont permis
de localiser le problème qu'on a sur
paris ça vient de chez vous vous avez un
ordinateur est-ce que vous appuyez sur
entrée en prenant un vrai clavier voilà
vous êtes invité à l'émission surprise
sur prise monsieur
[Applaudissements]
j'ai fait la nique était pirates
informatiques et qu'ils pouvaient faire
éteindre les lumières de paris avec un
ordinateur et ça c'était non masqué le
budget ces pièges à l'époque ça coûtait
cher 1,6 à bout formidable parce que
c'est ça qui fait monter
et moi j'étais tellement à côté j'ai
pensé qu'un truc c'est comment ce type
il va se faire massacrer par la police
donc je connaissais pas personne pour
l'aider et quand c'est quand ils m'ont
fait j'ai un truc est apparu surprise
surprise chez lui à marquer surpression
fait
[Rires]
j'ai déjà été en classe avec une star de
télé réalité bon certes eu certains va
mieux avec steam cloud
comme c'est le cas des trucs qu'on
traîne ses membres
du team blot
voilà et je voudrais juste lui donner un
petit conseil parce que l'un l'a dit en
fait comparé le coran la virus au camp
de concentration de petits conseils kim
n'hésite pas à va fermer ta gueule au
maximum
[Musique]
merci voilà petit lit on en voit avec
plaisir voilà les formules de politesse
et reste sur ces mots là qui sont
simples mais on a notamment du repas à
faire des phrases je t'embrasse et
continue à faire ce que tu fais c'est à
dire
des maillots de bain
vidéo par le confinement est patent en
vrai moi mais en fait souvent dans mon
jeu c'est un endroit où je me détends et
vous voilà théâtre est important de se
laver voilà j'ai déjà été confondu avec
un autre acteur a bavé gérard vardon
s'est passé vous faites une sur deux
c'est toi regarde regarde et je n'ai pas
mis city qui avait été abaissé à faire
faire ça ce ne sont qu est ce qu un faux
pas le jamais le faire c'est parce que
michel avec toute l'amitié il est comme
il est chauve c'est gérard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
seuls blancs
[Rires]
mais gérard est ce que ce n'est pas que
je t'ai gondolier
c'était pas mal c'est bizarre parce
qu'il ya toujours eu des journalistes
hyper pointu
est-ce que ce qu'on a déjà pris pour un
autre acteur
avec francis boy que j'ai rencontrés
pour la première fois est présenté je
vous connais pas bien la rondelle et ni
même à ma clope ma collaboratrice donc
aller beaucoup mieux les spécialistes
des cinémas numériques et chine qu'elle
n'est pas michel blanc
cette magnifique c'est le temps laurent
la chaîne conneries ah ben si l'accord
serré jusqu'au bout c'est sûr que dans
et toi tu saoules or en a tout le temps
complet vraiment comprendre pour laurent
laquelle et ce qui est bien c'est ouais
ouais lui il a maigri ah oui car je suis
sensible en avant
[Applaudissements]